oh non
d
oh
quarante ans après avoir chanté au
palais des congrès de paris le monde est
stone dans l'opéra rock starmania
fabienne thibeault se fait encore
arrêtée dans les rues de la ville
lumière et c'est vrai que starmania avec
entre autres le monde est stone et juin
contre les autres je suis marqué à jouer
starmania de michel berger et luc
plamondon a d'abord été handiski en 1978
puis il a été présenté pour la toute
première fois sur scène en avril 1979 au
palais des congrès de paris
un événement culturel historique diane
dufresne france gall et nanette workman
qui chantait entre autres des histoires
d'amour est probable planté dans la
ville futuriste de monopolis starmania
c'est le nom de l'émission de télévision
dans l'histoire le livre est signé
plamondon et visionnaire féministe
critique du capitalisme est encore
aujourd'hui
troublant d'actualité aujourd'hui on
peut planter mes personnages dans la
réalité
parmi les personnages il y à zéro
janvier un milliardaire égocentrique et
marie jeanne la serveuse automate
incarné par fabienne thibeault
[Musique]
quand lieutenante enduit ma vie alors je
sais pas en fait mais moi je trouve que
marie-jeanne chez moi ouais tu m'as
de 10 ans
mais starmania c'est aussi l'histoire de
plusieurs chansons qui ont été de grands
succès à la radio qu'on pense aux blues
du businessman
j'aurais voulu être un artiste
[Musique]
ces options de vente belges parce que
c'est c'est le monde est stone parce que
c'est une chanson qui on sait pas
comment elle fait
en entrevue l'été dernier le clamant
dont nous a confié que starmania et son
oeuvre est la plus réussie des chansons
de starmania sait quelque chose
la part complètement c'est au dessus de
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
au fil des ans starmania été présenté au
québec et ailleurs dans le monde dans
différentes versions
martine st-clair a joué dans la première
mouture québécoise et dans la reprise à
paris qui a été une belle vitrine pour
les artistes d'ici on était vraiment
dévasteur on avait des fans qui nous
attendait à chaque spectacle
des centaines de femmes qui nous
attendait à 11 heures à minuit aux
répétitions ou oui vraiment on avait des
cadeaux je revenais à montréal et dit
tout
[Musique]
martine st-clair fait encore un tabac en
interprétant les airs de starmania tout
comme luce dufault qui a campé le rôle
de mary jane au début des années 90
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
à l'époque c'est sûr que c'était
complètement fou où j'ai pu savoir plus
et tout c'est vrai plus ça ressemble à
ce qu'on vit à ce qu'on voit
malheureusement mais malheureusement
mais ça vieillit bien parce que parce
que les toons sont et 40 40 ans plus
tard la mémoire de starmania et bien
vivantes ici au québec et de paris où
elle habite fabienne thibeault a écrit
un livre sur cet opéra rock qui a changé
sa vie nous sommes très très nombreux
artistes avant je pense qu' aucun n'en
est sorti
[Musique]
ici le wifi depuis mai brasucade à
montréal
[Musique]